ERIC KOLEDA: Hello
and welcome.
My name is Eric Koleda.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Arun
Nagarajan here.
ERIC KOLEDA: And this
is Connecting
Apps Script and Twilio.
And today is a very exciting
special Google Developer Live
episode, where we're going to be
breaking the boundaries of
Google Apps Script, getting
beyond the web page and into
the world of the phone.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Sure.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Good morning to the folks that
are watching in from the West
Coast, quite early there,
or the East Coast.
And what we're going to do today
is talk about connecting
Apps Script applications to
voice and SMS messaging.
So Twilio is a cloud
communication platform that
allows you to take your
applications and connect them
to a phone call, send and
receive SMS messages.
And we're going to show a
few examples of that.
And hopefully everything we've
done is using the standard,
documented API.
And you'll be able to take a
lot of these away and build
your own exciting voice
and SMS applications.
ERIC KOLEDA: Just to clarify,
Twilio, that's not a Google
product, is it?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: No, it's
a third party product.
And we're just demonstrating the
other applications that we
can connect in using our
standard mechanisms, using
documented APIs from other third
party companies as well.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That's a good point.
Apps Script, the name implies
that it's all
about Google Apps.
But really you can integrate
with a whole
bunch of external systems.
You did Salesforce just
the other week.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
So here's yet another one.
Hopefully it'll get you excited
and you can see some
of the possibilities
that we offer.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sounds great.
Let's get rolling.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
So the first thing that I'll
start with is we'll talk
about, how do we process
incoming SMS?
One of the benefits of
SMS is that it's
such a global mechanism.
All you need is a
feature phone.
It's dirt cheap.
It's something that everybody
has access to.
They don't have to have a
specific type of smartphone.
They may not even need
to have a data plan.
So that's one of the nice
things about SMS.
And that's something that Twilio
has enabled worldwide.
And what we're going to show
is a very simple example.
The user sends an SMS.
The server gets it and does
something interesting with it
and responds back.
And hopefully that will set the
stage for how do you go
about building a simple
SMS application.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That sounds like a
great base case.
I actually just saw a
presentation recently about
how in developing countries SMS
is the backbone of almost
everything.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: So this is really
kind of an important thing.
And even in the US, sometimes
it's just
easier to send a text.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
So what I'm going
to do is go to
script.google.com to get started.
And I'm going to write a very
simple application.
I'm going to log in as myself.
Good.
So I'm going to start
a blank project.
So before I do the project
here, what I should have
pointed out is I've already
logged into my Twilio account.
So I've already set up
a Twilio account.
It's pretty easy
to get started.
They have a trial period as
well, so if you want to
experiment with the few basic
messages, you can do that
very, very cheaply.
So what they have is basically
the ability that you go into
their dashboard and if you
go to their numbers--
so essentially you purchase
numbers as part of the plan.
And I have a very simple plan,
a number that I've purchased.
It's a regular 10-digit
number.
You can actually get short codes
for a little bit more
money as well.
And what you can do here is
essentially you can attach a
call-back URL for each number.
So I've already done this.
And I'll come back.
And that's sort of the
background set-up
that I had to do.
And they have a couple of demo
URLs that they start you off
with, and then you can
obviously swap that
with your own URL.
ERIC KOLEDA: Just to be clear,
I think you mentioned briefly
that there is some basic
cost involved in
getting this running.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah.
So I forget the exact
specifics.
I think it's on the order of
a few cents a message.
And maybe even one cent for an
SMS message, and maybe 10
cents for a phone call,
something along those lines.
And then for those premium
numbers, you end up paying I
think a few bucks a month.
ERIC KOLEDA: So you can
definitely get started quickly--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Absolutely.
ERIC KOLEDA: --without a lot
of money being spent.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Absolutely.
And then they have really good
documentation as well.
So I'll show you that here's
sort of their documentation
for what happens for
an incoming SMS.
So an incoming SMS, you can
do a get or a post.
And here are the parameters that
come in, from, to, body.
And they do what you'd expect.
And then if available, it'll
actually do a whole bunch of
other geocoding as well, and
take the phone number and
convert it to city, state, and
country in some cases.
OK.
Let's go back.
And what I'll do is I'll use
our Language app to very
quickly translate an example.
So I'll say var incoming equal
to e.parameter.body.
I think it's lowercase B,
if I remember right.
All right.
Cool.
So I have that.
So that just is the
incoming SMS body.
I'm going to ignore the phone
number and other details about
the person.
I'll zoom in a little bit
so you can see this.
And what I'll do is I'll say
var translated equal to
LanguageApp.translate, and
translate incoming, which is
in English to Spanish.
And then I'm going
to respond back.
And one of the things I'm sure
you've seen in other examples,
and our documentation talks
about this quite a bit as
well, is content service.
So in the doGet method, you can
return a UI app instance,
HTML service, and the third
option, which we're going to
be using quite a bit
is content service.
Content service is what you can
do to return JSON, XML,
RSS, any sort of text-based
format that another computer
or another system needs
to interact with.
So in this case, we'll just
return simple text.
And we'll say return
ContentService.c
reateTextOutput.
And I'll return translated.
And then I'll just set the
MIME type manually,
ContentService.MimeType.text.
So you can see those are the
MIME types that we support.
All right.
And that's it.
So I'll save this as "translate
text," give it a
simple name.
We've got to have
a version saved.
And then I'm going to publish
this as a web app.
ERIC KOLEDA: So he was kind of
going through this fast.
But if you go to our
documentation, it'll show you
step by step how you can
do this end project.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
Absolutely.
I apologize if I'm skipping
through it quite quickly.
But what I've basically done is
saved a version, which then
allows me to deploy
it as a web app.
So one thing that you have
to make sure that you're
deploying it so that
anyone has access.
You don't have to publicize the
URL, but this is something
that you have to do
so that this other
service can call it.
I'm going to deploy it.
And that's it.
So that's a live Apps Script
content service app that's out
on the internet now.
I'm going to copy this URL, go
back to my Twilio dashboard,
and paste it in.
So clear this and paste in my
new example and hit Save.
And that's it.
So now I have a live
SMS application.
And hopefully we'll
get to testing.
So here's the code.
I'm going to go to my phone.
So this is quite exciting.
We have a live phone
hooked up.
Hopefully this will all work.
I'm going to go in, and the
number, I have it written out
here, so I'll just
type in 224--
that's the text message number
that I've purchased--
3902.
And we'll say "hello in
English." And this should--
you can see that it's
going through.
That should now call into
our Apps Script server.
And if the demo gods are with
us, we should get a text
message back.
Drum roll, please.
Maybe not so lucky.
Let's see.
What's going on here?
I'll go to the logs.
Did I mess something up?
You can see all the different
text messages
that are coming in.
So from, to, the messages.
Hmm.
Did I mess up the number?
Oh.
I texted some wrong person.
[LAUGHTER]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
exciting.
ERIC KOLEDA: At least the
message content was nice.
It was a greeting.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It
was appropriate.
That's right.
677-3902.
I'll just say "hello," save
myself a little bit of typing.
So that should now hopefully
show up in the logs here.
So it received it.
And it should have sent it.
And incoming, received.
And what's going on here?
Let's see.
390--
Huh.
Let's see here.
Go back to my service, Publish,
Deploy as web app.
Hopefully I copied
that correctly.
Am I missing something here?
ERIC KOLEDA: So what about
your publish settings?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
Let's see.
Deploy as web app, anyone.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes.
So you need to do as you.
Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
ERIC KOLEDA: So there are a
bunch of different ways that
you can deploy a web app in
Apps Script, whether the
script runs as the user account
that's actually
accessing it, or whether
it runs as a developer.
Now since Twilio doesn't have a
Google account, they're not
actually a Gmail user, it
couldn't actually run as them.
So it was asking them for
a login screen and
we couldn't do it.
[DING]
So now that it runs as Arun, you
can hear that ding means--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Let's say, "good morning." And
hopefully that'll work.
And you saw the mistakes that
I was warning you about.
So you have to just make sure
that the authorization
settings are set up correctly.
[DING]
And I'm not a very good Spanish
speaker, but hopefully
you can see that responding
in Spanish.
ERIC KOLEDA: Buenos dias.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So what I had
done, Eric pointed out, was
basically under the Deploy,
ensure that you're running it
as yourself.
And then anyone, even anonymous,
has access to this.
So that will set up the very
basic flow of getting a
message and then responding
back to it.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
It's incredible that in
basically three lines you've
been able to turn your phone
into any sort of
service that you want.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
And you can wire up-- and
obviously you just saw a very
simple Apps Script
service here, the
Language app that we used.
But then you have Finance.
You have all the other ones that
you can authenticate as
yourself and be able to access
your Documents, access your
Spreadsheets, access email
and Calendar and so on.
You have the whole suite of
tools available for you.
So that's a very simple example
of how this all works.
And hopefully that made sense.
And hopefully you saw
the few ways you can
screw that up as well.
So I'll close this.
And we'll actually go
to a fun example.
So the second example that
we're going to do is talk
about how we will take an SMS
feed from a user and convert
that into sort of a
polling mechanism.
So I'm sure you've seen this
on various shows like
"American Idol." And you
just text in your vote.
And they do that because they
want it to be very quick and
not have people go search for
an app and install it, which
for a simple one or two
character input, that's ideal.
A text message is ideal.
So what I have for this is I
kind of already started a very
simple spreadsheet.
Hopefully you can
see my screen.
So here you can just see that
I've started a very simple
spreadsheet where I just
have one row that
just shows the header.
And I've already written out
a very simple script.
And in this case, it's a very
similar format as the other
example you saw, except in this
case it takes the body
and then does some basic
processing on it.
And for lack of creativity, the
very simple poll here is
who your favorite
superhero is.
And who's your favorite super
hero, in my case, I have three
options and an other option.
And it's going to do a very
basic sanity checking.
It's going to actually
lowercase it.
And then if it doesn't match
any of these three options,
it's going to assume
you want "other."
And then it's going to take
that data and append it.
And then I'm going to return
nothing, so that there's no
cost associated with replying
back to this message.
OK?
And so what I'm going to do is
publish this as a web app.
I have this version,
update it.
Hopefully I'll do this right.
Make sure that I have the
settings correct here.
All right.
Cool.
Good.
ERIC KOLEDA: So now you're
just going to
reuse that same number?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Exactly.
For this purpose I'm not going
to set up a new number.
I'm not running a business.
This is just a sample.
So I'll just go back
to my account,
go back to my numbers.
ERIC KOLEDA: So I guess normally
if you wanted to have
multiple scripts each having
their own number, you'd have
to set it up.
You couldn't overload
like this.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
That's right.
Yes.
I'm going to save changes.
All right.
Cool.
And then I'm going to
go back to my phone.
And you can see that--
and Eric, you can try
along as well.
And the question was, who is
your favorite superhero?
And you don't have to tell me.
You can just vote in.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes.
We could be starting a Marvel-DC
war right here.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Cool.
I know who mine is, so
I'll just vote in.
And you can start seeing that
these things are getting
recorded automatically into
this little spreadsheet.
So this takes the user, their
input, and then starts
recording it.
And I don't have any sanity
checks today to prevent
multiple inputs.
So I'm just going
to start sending
in a few text messages.
And I'll vote for Superman
multiple times.
ERIC KOLEDA: We know
who you picked now.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I said it.
ERIC KOLEDA: The gig is up.
All right.
Cool.
Well, I've started to log it.
But now let's do something
interesting with it.
So let's take this column,
and let's say
Insert, Data, Pivot Table.
And I'll add parse vote.
And I'll add just a count.
And it looks like some people
on the listen in live are
watching this as well.
So I'll say Insert, Chart.
And I'll just do this.
And you can see that
there's a--
oh, it's Superman.
Superman's winning.
I feel like I'm cheating.
But you can see how quickly
you're able to turn a simple
SMS sort of message application
into a live sort
of dashboard.
So you can have this up
and displaying in
front of a live audience.
And this will update
as inputs come in.
So you can start seeing that
this is fluctuating.
And so this was a very simple
poll that we built in a matter
of seconds.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's amazing.
I mean, to get all the way from
people sitting in their
chairs to a live dashboard
with the results.
I mean, that was like only
a couple of minutes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
So I think what I may have done
here is only to restrict
it a few range.
So let me just make sure
that I include--
I don't know-- let's
go up to 99.
ERIC KOLEDA: I see.
So all the new results.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All the new
results weren't coming in.
So yeah, you guys get the
idea of this as being--
oh, there it is.
And it's updating.
So hopefully that gave you a
sense for how tapping in live
data works.
And let me actually go
ahead and delete
this and start over.
Insert, Chart.
And that should be a better
sense for how things are.
So it sounds like Superman's
winning.
Excellent.
ERIC KOLEDA: Max Steel
gets the nod today.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And again, all
this code, just like the other
session, I've put it on
the GitHub page on
github.com/entaq.
And you can find all
the samples here.
You can follow along.
I commented as best I can.
It's more of a recipe than a
production-ready sample.
But yes, feel free to take
a look at it and
then go about it.
So we have shown two examples.
In one case the incoming
SMS is intercepted
and responded back.
In another case, an incoming
SMS, we took the content and
add it to a spreadsheet.
And once it's in a
spreadsheet, it's
automatically available for
charting, for pivoting and
publishing and all
that good stuff.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
And everybody knows how to work
with spreadsheets, right?
They can pull the data out.
They can send it around.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: They can tabulate
it manually if
they felt like that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah.
So that's the nice little
beauty of spreadsheets.
And actually, we're going to
show one other example.
In this case, we're actually
going to make-- actually, you
know what I'll do?
I'll actually show a diagram
that I pulled together.
Let me load this guy.
Hopefully it'll make sense.
OK.
So here's kind of the flow
of what we built.
So in my screen hopefully
you guys can see this.
The user is out there.
They send an SMS.
It goes to the Twilio service,
which knows to wake up and
then call our Apps Script
service, which knows to write
data to a spreadsheet.
That's really it.
So this sort of manual--
sorry.
This sort of automatic flow,
then combined with the fact
that you can build a very quick
chart or report in a
spreadsheet, is really what
makes this valuable.
And then the users are
watching that chart.
And you can have that on a
big monitor and lots of
fun things like that.
So the moment it ends up in a
spreadsheet you can start
doing some pretty interesting
things.
But then it doesn't
have to be.
It could have been a text
archiving service or something
along those lines, where you can
just have that end up in a
document or a spreadsheet
or a site, and so on.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
So this was all SMS so far.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
Two examples of SMS.
And hopefully that
all made sense.
And we'll actually step into
an interesting example
involving phone calls.
So in this example what we're
going to do is I have a very
simple scenario around
I'm a principal.
And I have a bunch of students
that in some cases they're
tardy or misbehaving.
And on a weekly basis I want
to make sure that their
parents are aware of this
behavior in class.
And I wrote a little
verbal call helper.
And this data could come in from
a teacher reporting in,
using a Google form.
It could be a roll-up based
on attendance records.
You can do a lot of interesting
things.
Have the data end up
in a spreadsheet.
And from there, you can set up
a little script that can read
data from there and make
the phone call to
the appropriate parent.
And as you can imagine, the
limits are quite high from
what you can build from there.
ERIC KOLEDA: So now this isn't
actually you picking up the
phone and calling or somehow
scheduling that.
This is all automatic?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: This
is all automatic.
So in this case, the only thing
I'm going to kind of
manually trigger is
the script itself.
But as you can imagine, that
could be on an event-based--
you kind of talked about a very
sort of useful example
around triggering something
every hour, every week.
And you can start doing some
pretty interesting things.
And for this example, what I've
done is actually I've
assigned a little drawing.
And you can assign
a script like so.
So you just have a little
example where you can drop in
a little drawing that can look
like a button, build a little
interface-like widget.
And you press it and then
a script is called.
And before we go into the code
itself, I'll show you a very
quick example of
how this works.
So I'm going to click this.
Go back to my phone,
make sure--
I'm going to click this.
It doesn't want to run.
Maybe it doesn't like
the zoom level.
Let's see.
Did I remove the script?
Ah.
In showing you that, let me make
sure that is the right
script function.
OK, cool.
So I'm going to click this.
So the script runs.
And going back to
my phone here.
[PHONE RINGING]
Phone's ringing.
I'm going to pick this up,
pretend to be this parent.
COMPUTER - MALE VOICE:
Your daughter was
tardy to class again.
[COWBELL]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So you
can see that--
[LAUGHTER]
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
a little bit of fun.
I can show you what
happened there.
So you can see that this message
was read, first of
all. "Your daughter was tardy
to class again." And I also
played a little cowbell music.
ERIC KOLEDA: Need
more cowbell.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Absolutely.
That's actually a good segue
to show you the code.
So the way this works is Twilio
has a markup language
where you can have it read an
XML file which describes what
message to play, what sounds to
play it in, and then even
an MP3 that you may
want to show.
So you just saw that in a man's
voice, US accent, the
message, which is parameterized
in this
template, was said.
And then it would be
followed by playing
their cowbell.mp3 example.
So let's actually tweak
this a little bit.
And I'll have it say
it as a woman.
And we'll actually loop
that three times
for a simple example.
And I'll come back to this.
So this HTML is actually a
TwiML, I think is how they
pronounce it.
It's basically a simple XML file
and it's parameterized.
ERIC KOLEDA: Twilio tells
you that format.
There's documentation.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
It's documented.
And you can do lots
of useful things.
And you can have different
accents and
different MP3s and whatnot.
And here you can see that
what happens is--
two things happen.
So in the very first function,
we're reading through the
spreadsheet.
For this example I'm just
picking the first row.
And you can have it kind
of walk down the tree.
And what we're doing here is
we're calling a service with
the message to play as sort of
a cookie, which then it's
going to call back.
And we have to authorize this.
So this is an authorized call.
And then here's the URL
we're posting to.
All this you can follow along
on GitHub as well.
And then what happens
essentially is Twilio then
wakes up and calls the service
back and says, OK, I got your
request for a phone call.
What do you want me to say?
At this point, we read
this template.
We set the message property that
we sort of attached to
the URL so that we don't have
to save state anywhere.
And then it just reads
that and returns it.
So previously we were returning
content service as text.
This time we're returning
it as XML.
So for voice, you need to
interact with it as XML,
because it's actually a much
more richer interface.
So I'm going to save
this new version.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's right.
Since you changed the template,
in order for your
script to now respond with this
new data, you need to
update the version.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
I'm going to update this.
And what I'll do is I'll
actually go ahead and go back
to my call log.
And I'll zoom in a little bit.
Let's say, "Live demo, please
work." So this could be
something that you could have
automatically read.
I'm going to start calling.
And I'm going to manually run.
[PHONE RINGING]
Phone call comes in.
Answer.
COMPUTER - FEMALE VOICE:
Liv demo, please work.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So hopefully
you heard that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Liv demo.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It said
"liv demo." [LAUGHS]
But you got a couple examples
of how that works.
And so it's actually really
straightforward to kind of
have the service wake
up and call you.
ERIC KOLEDA: So it's a
multi-stage process here I
guess that we're dealing with.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yes.
So I have a little diagram
to illustrate this.
So the user triggers
the script.
So that's what the button did.
But that could be based on
a clock trigger as well.
From there, we send
Twilio a post call
saying, OK, here's me.
I'm authorizing myself.
Now wake up and call this other
URL, which contains the
XML feed, because it
could be a sort of
a multi-stage process.
Once the XML is woken up, it
could have sort of a directory
style, press one to get this.
So you can have an actual
conversation going as well.
Then Twilio, like I said,
comes back and
calls the same service.
So this could have been
hosted elsewhere.
But in this case, since I'm
reading from a spreadsheet
anyway, I kind of had it hosted
within the same service.
So it looks more like a loop.
But it could have forked
off into a
separate thread all together.
And then the user finally
gets a phone call.
ERIC KOLEDA: Gotcha.
So as you were saying, right
now it's just getting the
initial phone call message
and sending it back.
So there could be further back
and forth interactions.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah.
And they have a really good
example here about a company
directory that you could build
using this whole system.
So if you have 15, 20 people
in your department and they
have different cell phone
numbers and you don't want to
memorize them, you could hand
out a single phone number to
all your customers and
your partners.
And they call this number and
they may punch in the first
few digits of your extension
or first few
characters of your name.
And then in this example,
they're using a MySQL database
and a PHP script, but you can
see very quickly that this
could all work off of a
spreadsheet and Apps Script.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
pretty cool.
Thinking about Twilio here
is that they're very
lightweight, right?
Give them a URL and they'll
just make your app work.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I think Apps
Script really fits in well
here, because you can spin up a
quick URL web app that just
takes a little data
in, spits a little
data out, really quickly.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah.
That integration glue capability
of Apps Script I
think really stands out in this
example where we can be
invoked and we can invoke
other services.
And we can send up post
messages, standard HTTP
authorization headers, and
we can read incoming post
parameters, get parameters,
and so on.
And obviously all the backing
capabilities of Apps as well,
so into a spreadsheet,
into Google Contacts.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
When you said company directory,
I thought Google
Contacts right away.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Absolutely.
It makes a lot of sense.
And this is something that you
could use to make your company
look a bit more professional,
purchase a number, pay a
nominal fee for it, and then
get big time directory-type
capabilities so that you don't
have to have a receptionist
just sending messages
to the right person.
So that's the third demo that I
wanted to show, where you're
able to add voice capabilities
to a simple spreadsheet or
other Google App that
you may have.
Cool.
So let's see.
I mean, obviously one of the
things that I want to make
sure that you guys saw was all
the different capabilities
that you could very
quickly wire up.
And it definitely
makes sense to--
wrong window--
it definitely makes sense to
take a look to the APIs.
They've done a really good job
of documenting the SMS
messages, the voice messages,
how to intercept incoming and
outgoing, and send outgoing
SMS and voice messages.
And it is all based on verbs.
So you can see in this case for
the XML, I can do a lot of
interesting things.
One example that they have that
I think it's a little
harder to demonstrate is a
conference calling mechanism.
So you could write a little app
that ahead of a conference
call that you have.
It could wake up and open a
calendar entry and call all 15
people on the call and then
essentially join you into that
conference call.
So you could have an automated
conference call so you don't
have to type in those 10 digits
followed by the 6-digit
PIN and pound and one to
continue and stuff like that.
So it allows you to do a lot of
interesting things that you
may not previously have thought
about as an important,
or a possible integration.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
These aren't necessarily
something that you thought was
possible, well, it would take
me a week to do this.
It seems like it's impossible.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: And not only
is it possible, but it's
extra-simple.
That's pretty amazing.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And obviously, keep in mind that
this is all running on
top of the Apps Script
infrastructure.
So you'll have to think about
authentication and quotas and
things like that.
So there's a little bit
more than I'm showing.
But I think once you think
through what's possible, I
think you'll be able to figure
out what's appropriate for
your department or your team
and apply it from there.
ERIC KOLEDA: Now, these
docs look great too.
And I've also heard that they
have a developer relations
team that's actually
pretty active.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
right, yes.
ERIC KOLEDA: Kind of
our counterparts.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
Yeah.
And we work with them
quite a bit.
And I've actually spoken at
their meet-up, I think back in
late October.
And that was quite fun to be
able to show them that this
service can be hooked into the
Google Apps ecosystem, which I
think is a very broad one.
So if you tweet at them or you
go on their site, they have I
think like a Stack Overflow
label as well,
just like we do.
And I'm sure we can provide
support together.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sounds great.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And that's really all we have.
And hopefully this
all made sense.
And let us know what
you're building.
And we'll be happy to
highlight those.
ERIC KOLEDA: Thanks so
much for showing
us everything today.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Absolutely.
Thank you.
ERIC KOLEDA: Have a good day.